streets littered with burnt garbage and
broken windows as the cleanup began the
day after a pension reform protest and
the city descended into chaos paris's
mayor said she understood people's
frustrations but criticized some of
their methods
the violence that we condemn that I
condemn distracts attention from the
main issue which is that most French
people want the withdrawal of the
pension reform
some protesters and police clashed in
several French cities overnight police
unions said more than 400 officers in
the country were injured King Charles
was due to visit Paris and just a few
days but seems like this and more
planned protests have prompted the Elise
Palace to postpone the trip
at an EU Summit in Brussels president
macro said the king would be welcomed
another time
we would have lacked common sense if
we'd held a state visit for his majesty
the king and the queen consort in the
midst of the protests and given the
esteem and the friendship we feel for
his majesty the king and the queen
consort and the British people I made
the decision to call him this morning
and tell him what the situation was
trade unions want Emmanuel macron to
scrap the pension reform they say it's
unfair and will hurt poorer workers but
macro says it's necessary to sustain the
retirement system a standoff that seems
unlikely to end soon
Natasha buckler Al Jazeera Paris